we are bedeviled by the mysteries of
creation science can reveal the truths
that lie behind these many questions hey
guys we're here at Blizzcon 2017 I'm
Justin hey won't joined by Eric Tay and
we saw some pretty cool overwatch stuff
now the biggest thing to me is that they
were able to keep all of this a secret
like I had no idea that they were
actually gonna have a new hero and a new
map but oh my god that map is so cool so
they're not gonna say this but it feels
very much like it's modeled off of
Disneyland which is so close here to
where Blizzard convention takes place
because you have that feel not only of
kind of the futuristic land which is
kind of StarCraft II you have the
Haunted horror Diablo II type area you
have the the magical kingdom which is
world of warcraft like all of those kind
of come together to to feel Disney and
fun like but but with that with that
Blizzard overwatch feel which it's just
fun to explore like I love just walking
around the map and seeing the here's the
park layout did you what were there any
small details that you noticed it was
really hard cuz I was just playing Wario
which you know obviously was a big deal
to but just the attention to detail like
all the posters you know set in an
overwatch world obviously but very theme
park esque
the map just for like the theme park of
like here's where this is here's where
that is is so Disney asked like when you
see frontier land and like Tomorrowland
I don't even know what Tomorrowland
exist anymore but like you know when
they're gonna have Star Wars and it was
just like wow this is kind of scary to
think that that could be a reality
someday maybe like I'd go I'd go you
know but hey but really like I think
that's that's a nice little touch but
really more as the bigger deal here as
mentioned finally get a new support hero
a new support with a lot of a DPS feel
like it's definitely a healer I feel
like more than anything but but in the
right hand she could be a pretty
powerful dps character yeah her main
left-click ability biotic grasp allows
it has a dual purpose but essentially
well left and right click it lets you
not only heal your teammates it kind of
has a meter so you can't just like spam
it which is good it has relatively good
range so you know you can heal the
your teammates in front of you that are
weak or you can use your her right-click
ability which is kind of like a long
range DPS ability that's kind of like
some extras like beam turret kind of
thing so that's kind of cool and her
ultimate coalescence it's just a lot of
fun to use then it's just this beam that
shoots out it's so animated like I feel
like I'm playing an anime character what
I'm playing is her yeah and it's awesome
because that ability has dual purpose
right it's just totally fits with her
character another one of her abilities
the biotic sphere I think it's what's
called she throws out a little bouncy
ball again with dual purpose it can
bounce around and heal your allies or it
can bounce around and do damage to the
enemy which is awesome she was which one
that's gonna be when you when you fire
it off so it's either gonna be a healing
ball that bounces around or it's gonna
be a damaging ball yeah so yeah again
dual purpose like you see her left and
right hand it's like which one you want
to do you want to shoot out the heal the
light or do you want to kind of go dark
and and do damage to the opponents so
also fun ability and her last ability
which is a movement ability is pretty
cool it's it's called fade it gives you
the ability to kind of teleport like
left-right straight and behind you can
kind of control that as you're
teleporting is what I found but it
doesn't let you kind of like vertically
go anywhere from the times I try to
experiment with that but you're
invulnerable during that so you know
good to use when someone's like
harassing you or damaging you or if you
see like maybe a Widow's like lining you
up maybe you use that to kind of like
get away get to cover but yeah her walk
speeds okay so you're gonna definitely
need to use bait to kind of get to your
to your allies quicker but definitely
really fun like I plays in the auto a
lot so he and her kind of remind me of
the same thing which gives you the
ability to finally heal but also do
damage as a support
you know mercies damage is okay they
kind of buffed it at one point but uh
yeah just totally a fun character glad
supports finally got their due so both
of these both the map and Moira are
playable here at Blizzcon but those are
probably gonna be going into PTR really
soon I don't think we're gonna see them
out in the wild until next year hey said
early next year I believe but if you're
playing on PC you'll probably get a
chance to try it out soon but for other
Blizzcon stuff in other news for world
of warcraft overwatch and hearthstone
stay tuned to games bot calm
[Music]